this is our new baby the reg era ruggero  is Swedish for terrain like a ruler is  raining it's not three electrical motors  producing 700 horsepower it's got a  combustion engine producing 1,100  horsepower still the weight of the car  is 414 28 kilos dry weight and 1640 kerb  weight which is lighter than most other  of these hyper cars even though it has  more power bigger batteries than  anything else has that instant response  of an electric car with a massive torque  and power of our hub hyper cars combined  with almost no added weight top speed is  over 400 km/h the acceleration is are  staggering as we reach 400 in under 20  seconds so it's the fastest accelerating  production car ever is the most powerful  production car ever and it's being  obligated worldwide so we're selling it  on every market